I happen to love the game, Minecraft, along with a few other million people.
Yes, I built the teapot in the game. I even wrote a program to help me print 3D
models in Minecraft. But really, no, I'm not addicted at all. One confusing
thing in the game is the coordinate system. In the beta version of Minecraft,
the coordinate system was as follows, the X-axis points south, Z pointed west, Y
points up. You could tell these where the axis directions because in the game,
their sun rose in the east. When the game was released the developers changed
the direction the sun moved. The sun started rising and what I used to think of
was the south but was now considered the east. In other words, in release, the
X-axis now points east, Z points south, and Y points up. So, what handedness are
the beta and the release coordinate systems, right-handed or left-handed?